[Music]
[Music]
what up you just tapped into the group
chat live in the bleacher report app
presented by fanduel i'm greg ivory
alongside live moods today we are going
all in on the man i like to call 30 live
steph is two threes away from breaking
the all-time
record for three-pointers made and we
got a step boost for you a step three by
two and a step same game parley lift how
many threes do you think steph will have
by the time he retires
that's a tough question because i don't
know how long he's gonna be in the
league he is playing like he's gonna
stick around for a long time and if he
continues on the path that he's on right
now
the number will probably scare most of
us because he is definitely on fire from
the three so
time will tell but
it's gonna be a big one for sure
it's gonna be a big one that was a tough
question but
as always we're giving away locks we're
giving away hoodies and we're giving
away jerseys but today we're also giving
away liv
an iphone 13
after the game to one lucky commenter so
get in the comments get in the comments
you guys know what i need i need gifts i
need emojis but most importantly you
guys know that i need winners only
please
but i specifically want to see steph
gives today liv i want to see steph
gifts in the comments and uh
it's christmas season so why not give
away a jersey right now
why not give away a jersey right now
actually
i'll give away hoodies let's save the
jerseys for later live let's save the
jerseys for later i got joe
fabia joe fabia said steph is gonna get
steph is gonna break the record three
minutes and 23 seconds into
the first quarter so shout out to you
joe favia you are walking away with a
hoodie liv we asked everybody we asked
everybody watching we asked all of our
fans
in the app to tell us what
the exact time you think steph will
break the record tonight
i need you guys to get in the comments
and drop your guests for a chance to win
an iphone 13 at the end of the game well
dm one lucky winner and hook you up liv
do you even have an iphone 13 yet
i don't so i'm i i feel like i need to
get in the comments right now and make
my best guess
get
one hop on there you know i'ma look for
you i'ma look for you in the comments
leave i'm gonna look for you in the
comments hop on there hey i don't even
have an iphone 13 yet i like
i want to hop in the comments am i
eligible too like seriously uh but in
honor in honor of steph
uh potential record-breaking night
fanduel fandol is giving us the br super
boost on a special special steph prop
today
the question is will steph hit two or
more three-pointers and break the record
in the first quarter live uh fanduel is
boosting the odds from -110 to plus 150
liv do you like the plus money on this
i do and i always love plus money and i
will always take plus money if i think
that it's a good play and i do think
that this is a good place steph is
obviously going for a record-breaking
night he is trying to make history
so i love this play uh not only that i
know there are some people out there
that are probably a little bit nervous
about this back-to-back match-up for
this warriors team i know they were
stuck in indiana last night they were
having some mechanical issues with their
planes that was something that i thought
about this morning oh i'm kind of
nervous to ride with this warriors team
today but after doing some research i
realized steph curry
thrives on zero day's rest he absolutely
thrives earlier this season he had 50
points and nine threes on no rest
against the hawks
and in a separate game he had 27 points
and five threes on no rest against the
spurs it seems that no rest does wonders
for steph steph curry and you add in the
fact that he's trying to make history
tonight i think he gets hot immediately
coming out of the gates in the first
quarter so i do love this play and i
love that it's plus money
i love it too i love it too you
mentioned steph uh you you you mentioned
him breaking the record tonight you
mentioned him making three pointers
tonight but liv i want to tell the
people a very important
fact steph loves playing at madison
square garden he loves to play there i
see him getting this early i see him
getting this record early and uh putting
on the show for the people at the garden
i'm in the comments right now
i'm in the comments i'm giving away
hoodies and i'm also giving away a
jersey here live uh let me see what the
people are talking about if you guys
don't know this right here is the handy
dandy ipad handy dandy ipad this is how
you get your hoodies uh
here we go a ad when l says curry makes
history tonight yes sir we know curry's
gonna make history tonight but just
because you commented you were walking
away with a hoodie also uh
also i got winners only harturax hartrex
says winners only uh he's gonna do it
with two minutes and 56 left in the
second quarter wow two minutes and 56
left in the second quarter shout out to
you uh you were walking away hoodie i
got xkcx
xkcx this is the jersey winner right
here
she says steph got this
second quarter
seven minutes
14 left on the clock that's when steph
is going to knock it down so shout out
to you
xkcx you are walking away with a jersey
of your choice liv
it's tnt tuesday which means we got more
odds boosts for you fanduel is boosting
the 3x2 in both games tonight so you
know what that means liv you know we
calling it
three by tuesday the question is will
there be two three-pointers in the first
three minutes of
the game today we asked you on twitter
which 3x2 will catch tonight is it the
golden state warriors taking on the
knicks or is it the phoenix suns taking
on the portland trailblazers here are
the current results
okay liv i mean we have the steph curry
effect going on in the golden state
warriors neck game but live live live
live let's
there's shooters in that second game we
got phoenix taking on portland there is
shooters in that same game which one do
you like best
i mean you're absolutely right there are
shooters in that game as well and from a
defensive perspective the trailblazers
currently allow the fifth most threes to
their opponent and they defend the
three-point line the worst in the league
they allow their opponents the highest
three-point percentage in the league
right now so you take into account that
the fact that they have shooters and
they have poor perimeter defense i do
think that that portland uh phoenix game
is worth a little bit of a sprinkle
tonight in terms of three by tuesday but
i got a ride with the warriors i mean
steph is trying to make history this is
a warriors team that ranks second for
three pointers made and a knicks team
that ranks sixth i think it's gonna be a
three-point shootout i think steph curry
gets hot early because he's trying to
make history and he just continues to
shoot from the three-point line the
entirety of the game so i got a ride
with the
warriors and knicks in this three by two
but i do think the other one is worth a
little sprinkle especially when it's
plus money okay
yeah i i like that liv i like that a lot
but let's hop into the comments i am in
the comments seeing what they are riding
with i got enderman in the comments
saying golden state warriors taking on
the nick shout out to you enderman you
are walking away with a hoodie i got uh
maxo rexel in the comments talking about
sons
blazer shout out to you maxwell rex so
you're walking away with honey goat
garden says sun is is getting both shout
out to you go garden
uh
live i'm gonna make a i'm gonna okay
sandy goat says yes there will be two
both by curry curry cashing it all for
us
i'm gonna make a decision here liv
we are all riding it's steph's night
tonight it's steps night steph is at the
garden we are riding the golden state
warriors taking on the new york knicks
3x2
we need to see two of those go in in the
first three minutes believe we're not
only riding that one why not you said it
let's sprinkle it on the later game so
let's all get rich let's all get rich
last week
last week liv
i didn't hit but a lot of people hit on
the new york the all new york teen bing
bong parlay liv did you ride the bing
bong parlay
i didn't and i wish that i had i turned
i i went to twitter and my whole
timeline was just
bing bong this bing bong that money
emoji i mean everyone was cashing out on
this bing bong parlay so i definitely
dropped the ball not tailing that one
but uh we had a pretty solid week last
week even our three by two cash our same
game parlay cash the bing bong parlay
cash it was a hot and fiery week last
week we were all cashing out but i
missed the bing bong parlay i'm sad i
did but i'll get them next time
liv you missed it but they're running it
back tonight they are running it back
tonight and i greg ivory i'm telling you
guys do not take the bing bong parley
actually take the bing bing parley that
i got up on my story you guys go go to
my story on instagram you guys can see
the party that we are rocking because
the knicks and the nets are playing
tonight and we want to know if you're
betting the basketball bing bong parlay
we want to know get in the comments tell
us what you think the the odds are
currently at plus
298 for a knicks nets moneyline parlay
liv i don't like this at all
you know why i don't like this the
people in the comments know why i don't
like this talk to him they'll live talk
to him
do what do you think do you like this
uh
bing bong parlay
i you know i don't hate it um but the
only reason that i could see it hitting
is because of where the public money is
right now in these two games nearly 70
percent of public money is writing with
the warriors and over 70 percent of the
public is writing with the raptors
fading the public we've talked about
this a million times it's never a
horrible idea now obviously i think the
nets have a much better chance up
against the raptors than i think the
knicks do against the warriors i think
the warriors are winning tonight i think
it's all about steph curry tonight i
don't think that this next team is gonna
pull off an upset tonight however i
could see uh the part of this bing bong
parlay hitting is the nets i feel
comfortable with that bet
not so sure i trust the knicks to defeat
a warriors team that has so much writing
on it tonight and a hot steph curry to
me is just unstoppable so
i could see it for the sake of fading
the public but i don't love the knicks
play so
and i'm not biased i don't i don't have
a huge love for the warriors this is
simply coming from the fact that i just
think the warriors are the better team
so
maybe a little sprinkle on this one but
i don't love it because i'm rooting for
the warriors tonight
i mean you you you brought all your
statistics today living you've been
talking about the warriors on back to
back nights you've been talking about it
all
all day so uh
yeah um i don't like it obviously you
guys know i'm fading the bing bong
parlay we're riding with the being
parlay so let me get into the comments
let me see if some of y'all is rocking
with me and the bing bing uh here we go
i got goated goated swazi says bing bing
he is riding the bing bing parlay shout
out to you go to swazi you were walking
away with a hoodie uh uh
richie 21 says got it last week but
today it isn't hitting uh okay richie 21
shout out to you
um easy money 98 says bing bong shout
out to everybody that i've mentioned you
all are walking away with a hoodie live
it's time for my favorite part of the
show let's talk major markets money
lines against the spread and point
totals for tonight's game let's take a
look at the odds liv what are you seeing
here and what do you like
well right off the bat i'm loving over
211 for -112 odds in that warriors
knicks game like i said earlier like i
alluded to earlier i think this is a
three point shootout between these two
teams two teams the ranked top 10 and
three pointers made and
the warriors on no rest are two oh and
one
with the over they have hit the over a
hundred percent of the time on no rest
and this next team who's on two to three
days rest they have hit the over
three
two and oh time so 60 of the time they
have hit the over on two to three days
rest the warriors have hit the over 100
of the time on no day's rest that's
exactly the circumstance that we're
looking at tonight one team with no rest
the other with two to three days i like
the over tonight two eleven two teams
know how to shoot well from the three i
think the over hit so i'm liking that's
my best bet for tonight
liv is rocking with the over
i'm gonna keep it real simple with you
guys i have a parlay out right now it's
called the bing bean parlay it's on my
story you guys follow me greg three g's
underscore ivory you will see what i'm
talking about on instagram
so i'm gonna drop the warriors money
line you might be alarmed and say hey
greg it's minus 210 hey greg that's a
lot of juice no
go ride the bing bing parley it's just a
leg
of the parlay we're riding with the
warriors i'm in the comments i am in the
comments right now
giving away hoodies uh i got loso 98
they're just commenting on steph today
loso 90 says steph is going for 35 seven
threes tonight shout out to you loso 90
you were walking away with a hoodie uh
i got i got
george
george
neat
thoroughly says jake really going for
his prize i have no idea what you're
talking about no george but
i guess i'll just give you a hoodie just
because uh
julio hernandez says i agree with liv
the if this will be a shootout he's
rocking with you live uh giant smash is
going with the golden state warriors
over shout out to everybody that i
mentioned you all are walking away with
hoodies live
we talked major markets now let's talk
some player props it's time for luck or
not i'm gonna put up a prop and i need
all of you all of you in the audience to
get in the comments and tell me whether
this is a lock or not that's all i need
is lock or not guys lock or not there it
is liv are you ready
i am ready
liv's ready i'm ready let's get right to
it first up is chris paul to record a
double-double against the blazers it is
sitting at minus
110 liv
do you like this
is this a lock
or is it not
i do like it i i really do i think with
devin booker being out chris paul is
really stepping up into a more
leadership type role where he's not just
focusing on one thing or the other he's
kind of doing a little bit a little bit
of buffet style basketball if you will
he's picking and choosing here there
everywhere he's got to do a little bit
of everything he's the leader on this
team he's the veteran on this team
booker being out chris paul really has
to step up and do a lot of facilitating
uh even some rebounding even though
that's not his priority i think assists
and points i like this for him in the
last three games he's hit this in two of
the last three um
last game it seems like he was a little
off but it was up against the clippers
so maybe he just wasn't all the way
dialed in but i like it tonight up
against you know a trailblazers team
that
doesn't necessarily have the strongest
defense in terms of points allowed and
rebounds allowed as well as even assists
allowed so because of that weaker
defense for the trailblazers i like
chris paul to be able to get this double
double tonight so i like it i'm saying
it's a lot
i'm following you liv we all know what
chris paul likes to do he's the point
guard he's chris paul he loves the dish
to rock he loves to get his teammates
involved we know what he likes to do he
also is chris paul he's a scorer so uh i
see him getting this double double minus
110. uh it's a fair shot i see him
getting this in in this game against the
portland trailblazers uh let me see what
the people are talking
about let me see what people are talking
about they they're saying easy lock live
aspects 24 is dang gonna come out to
play uh okay shouts out to dame uh but
we're talking chris paul here uh here we
go oh okay i got maxwell wrestle says
chris paul double double it's a lot
maxwell wrestlers in the comment shout
out to you uh
i i got one more i got one more in me uh
bine to goat says easy lock greg easy
lock double dough for chris paul okay
shout out to everybody that i mentioned
you all are walking away with a hoodie
next up is damian lillard top scorer
tonight liv dame lillard top scorer
sitting at -150 do you like this
or do you not is this a lock or is it
not
i think it's a lock um i really do i
think obviously he's coming back he's
getting back in health he's getting back
on the court uh this is a damian lillard
that
knows how to shoot the ball he knows how
to score that's something that i've
never had to worry about with him ever
uh and he's going up against a sons team
that i think offensively kind of
distributes their points throughout the
majority of their starters there's not
one guy if there is one guy that's doing
the majority of the scoring it's booker
booker's not in so i do like damian
lillard to be that guy tonight uh like i
said he's coming back i've also seen a
lot of conversations about damien
lillard
potentially talking about wanting to
play other places other teams looking at
him he's looking at other teams this is
a great opportunity for him to come back
and show these teams what he's made of
and figure out where he wants to go
after his era is done with the blazers
if that's the case so i do like this
play with devin booker being out
especially i like this place so i'm
gonna take it damien lillard uh as the
top scorer tonight coming back i like it
i'm taking it it's a lot
i like the way you think liv i'll be i
like i like the way you think i like the
way you think but i just don't know if i
love it on this one i'm gonna go the
other way and i'll tell you why i'm
gonna go the other way because dame is
coming back from an injury
i don't know if he's gonna go through
the motions i don't know if he's gonna
get his legs right this game i don't
know if this is gonna be a conditioning
game for them and to lay minus 150 i i
just i just don't know if i'm willing to
lay my money on that with with all these
questions surrounding dane's health so
uh i'm gonna rock and lean the other way
but it's not about me it's about the
people in the comments
uh
i see davinci 17 says dang bucket bucket
bucket dame is a bucket shout out to you
da vinci you are walking away with a
hoodie uh finally liv finally we have
nurkic to grab 12 or more rebounds
tonight it is sitting at
plus 146 talk to me liv
is this a lock or is it not
no
absolutely not no no no no no i can't do
it i cannot do it to myself again i have
lost
way too much money on nurkic he has
games where he
is so electric and so aggressive and he
gets those boards and then you go to bed
on him and he's playing really soft
honestly and it's it's tough to bet on
so i refuse to lay my money with nurkic
ever again i can't do it to myself not
to mention he's going up against the
sun's team that has deandre ayton
that matchup i don't love for nurkic i
think that he plays too timid in terms
of getting those boards and ayton's
gonna eat him alive if he plays timid
tonight which i think he will uh i i
don't love this matchup for him
considering he's going up against a big
man like ayden who just dominates on
defense and getting those rebounds so
i'm gonna say it's a no he hasn't hit
this consistently in his last few
matchups either so that makes me feel
even more like it's not a lock but i
think you know i might be doing a little
bit of betting with my heart here i've
been burned by nurkic i'm not doing it
again so i'm saying it is not a lock
there's nothing wrong with that don't
let nobody
you can do whatever you want to do
but i'm going to talk about this pick
right now i'm going to talk about nurkic
because he's not going to be able to do
whatever he wants to do on the court
tonight he's and i don't think he's
going to be able to grab 12 rebounds
tonight and i'm going to tell you why
chris paul d'andrea and they like to run
the pick and roll they like to run the
pick-and-roll up top
usually that means
nurkic is going to switch on to chris
paul so he's going to be up towards the
perimeter he's going to be up towards
the perimeter he's not going to be able
to grab 12 rebounds with that philosophy
this is just not going to work also you
mentioned
deandre hayden
i'll take my chances on de'andre eight
and over nurkic in the rebounding
competition any day so uh i i don't like
this one i don't like this one i do not
think this is a lot i'm in the comments
right now liv i am in the comments
giving away
hoodies uh
uh oh mg 300 says eight and not planned
we have to we have to check the stats on
that uh we have to check the stats on
that we have to producer get in our ear
and let us know if he's playing or not
uh mari hernandez says hey greg and liv
i think easy lock for sure uh they're
riding the riding lift they're riding uh
i got one more one more
one more uh tai 17 said it is not a lock
it is not a lock shout out to you ty uh
let's move on let's move on everybody oh
everybody that i mentioned you all are
walking away
but it's time to build the br betting
custom par lay
whichever
which
you guys you guys at home can actually
ride with us on fanduel and we all know
what happened last week liv tell them
what happened last week
we cashed baby we cashed on the s yeah
on the three by two oh it was a great
night great night yes
we cashed y'all tonight on the inside
the nba pregame show chuck is gonna look
at our parlay and pick his favorite leg
now while i give out the parley i need
everybody to get in the comments and
tell me what y'all think tell me which
legs is is locked tell me which legs is
not tell me which legs is y'all go take
and put in y'all parlay just talk to me
in the comments this week we're building
a steph
game
parlay lift let's get right to it let's
get right to it the first leg
the first leg of this parlay
is
my guy steph curry making five threes
live
he just did this last night do you think
he could do it again
yep i sure do i sure do he is looking to
make history tonight like you said
earlier he plays very well at msg
so it's a big night for him tonight it's
a big big night i was seeing all these
posts about all these people that are
coming out to msg to watch him play to
watch him make history tonight because i
think everyone knows it's going to
happen five plus i'm not worried about
it i love it
liv loves it
okay live love you okay i'm feeling good
about this i'm feeling good about this
let's go to the next one let's go to the
next leg uh here we go next leg we're
staying with steph here liv we are
staying with steph here
30 plus points tonight do you think he
can do it
yes i do uh again all the variables that
are considered in the situation msg
trying to break history trying to break
records we love it but also on no day's
rest he's averaging 38.5
points so take into account the other
factors the other variables
30 plus i think is easy money for him i
could see him going into halftime with
16 17 points so yes i love this play
okay we got our two-step curry
legs of the parley now this one's this
one's interesting let's go draymond
green
six plus assist live honestly to me this
seems like it seems like but we know
he's gonna be feeding steph the rock all
game liv talk to me do you like this
i do i mean draymond green strikes me as
the guy slash teammate that wants to be
a part of this moment with steph he
wants to help contribute to this
historic night for steph curry uh
they're a dynamic duo these two i was
seeing a picture on twitter of them high
fiving when they were younger and
everyone kept saying we're gonna see
this again tonight they need to recreate
this photo i think draymond wants to be
as much a part of this special night for
steph as he possibly can be and the best
way for him to do that is to feed steph
the ball and i think that that's exactly
what he's going to do tonight so that
steph can make history they can win and
he can hit six plus so that we can catch
the same game parliament so i see it
working out for us let's go
let's go liv is sending us good vibes on
the parlay so far but liv
we took
your play and put it in the parlay you
mentioned the over earlier in the show
and that is the last leg of the parlay i
know you like it right you gotta like
this you mentioned it i do i love it
yeah i think it's a shootout tonight
both teams get hot from the three i
think it's a very high scoring affair i
love this one i really do and i think it
goes hand in hand with the rest of the
bets that we've got in the same game
parlay and that's key when you're when
you're creating a same game parlay is to
make sure that they that's a um
that they have chemistry with one
another you don't want to take yeah you
don't want to take it under and have
steph curry going off tonight those two
don't add up but we have steph curry
going off and we like
so it's perfect
absolutely absolutely liv uh let's put
the ticket up so we can show the people
how much money they go get if they was
to place this at the casino with fanduel
uh
you guys if y'all drop a hundred dollars
you're walking away with 500 and some
change there it is liv before i get into
the comments
last week
you gave us a b you gave us a b and we
hit
this week what are you grading the br
betting parlay
well because i have so much faith in
steph curry i want to bump it up to an a
but i'm thinking maybe i keep it at a b
just in case that b has a little extra
good vibes to us
apparently it did last week so maybe we
rock with a b
i'll tell you what i really like it
though i think steph curry has himself a
knight i have a lot of faith in him
tonight i love the parlay but we're
going to go with b because that's what
we had last week and we cashed so we're
going to keep the good vibes rolling
we're keeping the good vibes rolling
here uh
liv's giving us a b b gets degrees for
show b b's honor roll so i'm taking that
i am taking it uh i'm in the comments i
am in the comments giving away hoodies
and i'm also giving away a jersey uh
saliva so liba says
easy money
lay easy money parlay shout out to you
to leave that you were walking away with
the hoodie um
my boy big bry guy says been manifesting
the hoodie all week now i see greg got
the same
legs as me for the same game parlay it's
a dream meant to come true
big bry guy
you are walking away with a jersey i
love that i love that take i know you
want a hoodie
actually let's give him a hoodie and a
jerk why not let's get big bry guy
hoodie and another take i'm giving away
one more hoodie liv one more hoodie
rc italy rc italy says the whole thing
will hit bing bing let's go shout out to
greg right the way he's riding the bing
bing farley shout out to you uh you were
walking away with the hoodie live let's
talk futures
steph curry is the favorite to win mvp
i've been telling you guys that from the
beginning
telling you guys that
since the beginning like since the first
show i've been telling you guys that but
what i need you guys to do right now is
get in the comments and tell me if steps
should win mvp and if not
if not tell me who you think should
let's take a look at the latest odds
steph curry
currently is sitting at
plus
145 liv
what are your favorite bets on the board
honestly i think steph curry is exactly
where he's supposed to be as the
favorite uh you know he's doing he's
doing steph curry things there's no
other way to describe it i think kevin
durant is a pretty close second right
now with what he's doing with this nets
team being arguably the best scorer in
the league uh he creates opportunities
to uh get the ball in the basket and
it's pretty impressive to watch every
time he's on the court i keep you know
i'm blown away every time him and steph
both this year i think are pretty close
with one another in terms of that mvp
spot i actually sprinkled a little bit
on
john marant earlier this season at plus
3200 is what i grabbed it at obviously
him being injured was a huge blow uh to
my bet however he was he was really
adding a lot of value to that grizzlies
team i feel the same sort of way right
now about paul george at plus 5 000.
i don't think you should go and put your
college money or your rent on this play
however at plus 5000 it's worth a
sprinkle we're seeing what he's doing
with his clippers team
he is that guy for this clippers team
the only reason they're really winning
any games right now is because of paul
george and if that's not valuable i
don't know what is so i think paul
george is worth a little sprinkle right
now the value's great
again don't go put your rent money on it
but at plus 5000 i like those odds so
we'll see but i definitely yeah you
gotta roll with steph right now the way
he's playing basketball he's definitely
the the front runner for sure
definitely got a roll with steph i'm
taking steph said it before i'm gonna
say it again if it ain't broke don't fix
it get on steph curry i'm honestly
surprised i'm honestly surprised liv
that he's still plus money but i know
that it's we're still before christmas
like it's early yeah it's still early in
this nba season so uh take steph i'm
back into the comments giving away
hoodies
uh here we go uh
goat garden says they need kawhi shout
out to you go garden uh ak 47 big blue
curry is gonna win but if he slows down
the only person that can catch up is
giannis i don't think kd's gonna beat
him either that is a good take that is
actually a really good take
uh
giannis liv yana's coming out the
woodworks
maybe we don't know i like kd too i like
katie i think kd's the best player in
the nba uh right now but liv
our time has come to an end
it's time to sign out it's time to sign
up thank you guys for tapping into the
group chat
presented by fanduel remember what you
learned today get in the comments and
drop your best guess for when steph will
break the record
we're giving away an iphone 13 to
somebody in the comments so make sure
you guys uh drop that time uh draymond
should win defensive player of the year
we
we know that get on fanduel to tell our
special special special steph odds boost
the b ball bing bong and the br betting
same game parlay my producer wrote that
i did not say that i mean i did say it
but i did not write that do not tell the
bing bong you get on the bing bing
parlay check out my socials uh tune in
to the nba pregame show tonight to see
chuck pick his favorite leg of our
parlay we'll be back
next week liv we'll be back next week
giving out more hoodies more jerseys and
more locks if you want a hoodie today we
will dm you get on fanduel ride along
with us and follow us on social media
alongside live moods i'm greg ivory we
are leaving the group chat peace
[Music]
you